اهلا بكم لا تزالوا الاشتباكات في السودان
مستمره يدخل الملايين حول العالم اولى
ايام عيد الفطر لكن في السودان الوضع
مختلف لا افرح بالعيد فقط الحزن هو ما
يخيم على المشهد في ظل الاحداث الجاريه
السلام عليكم
ورحمه
كل شيء
تعني الكلمه من المعنى
لدمار وفقدان كل شيء حتى حتى حتى مالي
ملابسي
كل شيء كل شيء في الشقه تدمرت تماما هل لك
ان تصف لنا الحادث من بدايته
كنا نعمل
هذا اليوم الامس
في حدود الساعه حوالي الساعه الثامنه
والنصف صباحا
كعاده يعني كموظف
يعني ليا خبره في المجال الامني
اخذت كل كل اسرتي الى الصاله الخارجيه لكي
ننام ارضا
من جديد حاله من الذعر والخوف تنتاب
المدنيين في السودان على وقع زخات الرصاص
والمعارك الكثيفه التي حاصرت مساكنهم رغم
هدنه هشه كسابقتها ما دفع الالاف لجمع
امتعتهم والمصارعه بالفرار تجنبا لنيران
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
حاله الذعر لم تقتصر على المواطنين
السودانيين فقط بل امتدت الى الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه التي بادرت بعمليه
تنظيم رعاياها تمهيدا لنقلهم خارج السودان
بعدما بدات بالفعل دول مثل المانيا
واليابان خططا لاجلاء مواطنيها لكن من
المؤكد ان الاضرابات المستمره واغلاق
المطارات الرئيسيه ستعيق تلك الخطط مصادر
مطلعه افادت بان مهمه الجيش الالماني
لاجلاء نحو 150 المانيه من السودان ارجات
بسبب القتال الدائر في العاصمه الخرطوم
وعدم التزام الطرفي الصراع بالهدنه
الثانيه التي تنتهي مساء اليوم كذلك تحدثت
اليابان عن وجود حوالي 60 مواطنا يابانيا
بينهم موظفون في السفاره بالخرطوم فمع
استمرار اغلاق المطارات تعتبر الامم
المتحده ان خطه الاخلاء الفوري جوا
مستحيلا ما دعا الى النظر في امكانيه
استخدام البريه رغم المخاطر الكارثيه التي
تحيط بها
حصيله قتل المواجهات متضاربه لكنها تجاوزت
مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وهي تبقى مرشحه
للارتفاع مع استمرار الصراع بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى من البلاد
ازمه تركت اثارها على الجوانب المعيشيه
للمواطنين وضاعفت اسعار المواد الغذائيه
حتى المرافق الصحيه لم تسلم كذلك من تبعات
الصراع حيث اجبرت المستشفيات المرضى على
مغادرتها لنقص امكانيات العلاج والاقامه
ومع استمرار الاشتباكات اصبح من الواضح
انه لا يوجد مكان امن في السودان لحياه
المدنيين
قلت مبادره القوى الوطنيه السودانيه انها
تحصلت على موافقه مبدئيه من اطراف الصراع
لوقف الاشتباكات خلال ايام العيد واكدت
المبادره انها ستقدم مبادره شامله لوقف
النار والحوار لحل الخلافات واشارت الى ان
نتيجه المساعي لمبادرتها ستكون خلال
الساعه القادمه
بحث رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان مع قاده عده دول عربيه
واقليميه وغربيه الوضع في السودان وذلك
حسب ما ذكر اعلام مجلس السياده التي قال
ايضا ان البرهان بحث مع قاده عده دول
عربيه واقليميه وغربيه الوضع الراهن حيث
اكد القاده للبرهان ضروره عوده الاوضاع
لطبيعتها كما اشار البيان الى ان البرهان
بحث مع وزيري الخارجيه السعودي والامريكي
فرص الحوار في السودان
قال فارس النور مستشار قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقله في تصريحات خاصه
للعربيه قال ان هدفهم هو التحول
الديمقراطي حتى وان كلف الامر استمرار
المعارك
الذي غلب الطاوله ان دعاه
الديكتاتوريه والذين يريدون ان يعودوا الى
النظام السابق حسوا ان القوه في السودان
صادغه في الوصول الى اتفاق ينتقل بها الى
الديمقراطيه فحسوا بالخطر فكانوا لابد
كانت لابد ان يتحركوا حتى ان يحافظوا على
مصالحهم وحتى يفشل هذا الامر وانا هنا
اقول اننا
ندعو جميع القوى المدنيه جميعها سواء
الذين في الاطار وغير الاطار الى الى
الاتحاد
وتكوين اكبر جبهه مدنيه لمواجهه هذا الخطر
لمخاطبه المجتمع الدولي بضروره الانتقال
الى التحول الديموغرافي
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها تراقب
الوضع في السودان مع استمرار المعارك هناك
وتجري تقييما لحالات اجلاء طارئه ويستعد
البنتاجون لارسال عدد اضافي من الجنود الى
معسكر التابع للبحريه الامريكيه في جيبوتي
ومن المتوقع ان تعمل القوات على تامين
وربما تسهيل مغادره موظفي السفاره
الامريكيه من الخرطوم اذا اقتدت الظروف
واشارت مصادر الى وجود اتصالات بين وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه والطرفين النزاع في
السودان لضمان عمليه الاجلاء
مازلنا قلقين للغايه بشان العنف والقتال
في السودان كان هناك ما يسمى بوقف اطلاق
النار الليله الماضيه ولم يصمت طويلا
وبالتالي لا يزال الناس يتعرضون للاذى ما
يمكنني قوله هو ان لدينا تواصل مع جميع
موظفين هناك الذين يعملون داخل وخارج
السفاره لا يزالون جميعا في الموقع نفسه
لا تزال وزاره الخارجيه والسفاره هناك
ميلان الحفاظ على سلامتهم اعلن البانتاجون
انهم يمضون قدما في التمركز المسبق لبعض
القوه والقدرات العسكريه في مكان قريب في
حاله الحاجه اليها لاي نوع من الاجلاء
في الاثناء حث المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه الاطراف المتنازعه في
السودان على تمديد وقف اطلاق النار حتى
نهايه ايام عيد الفطر مؤكدا ان تعرض
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين لاي هجمات او
مخاطر سيكون غير مقبول على الاطلاق
ان وقف اطلاق النار لمده 24 ساعه الذي تم
الاعلان عنه في التاسع عشر من ابريل تم في
الغالب بالتنسيق مع حلفائنا وشركائنا نحد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع على تمديد وقف اطلاق النار الحالي
حتى يوم الاحد الثالث والعشرين من ابريل
اي حتى نهايه العيد وكما اوضح وزير
الخارجيه انطون بلينكن ان اي هجمات
وتهديدات ومخاطر يتعرض لها الدبلوماسيون
الامريكيون فهي غير مقبوله على الاطلاق
وفي رد على سؤال لمراسل العربيه قالت
الناطقه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان هناك
ضغط دولي لتوصل الى هدنه في السودان بهدف
حمايه المواطنين والرعايه الاجانب مدام
اتصلت الوزيره كاترين كولو بنظيرها
السعودي وبالامين العام للامم المتحده من
ضمن سلسله اتصالات تقوم بها فرنسا حول
السودان هناك ضغط جماعي للوصول الى هدنه
طوارئ انسانيه ثم وقف اطلاق نار دائم مما
يجب ان يسمح بالخروج من الازمه يجب ان
تسمح الهدنه ايضا بحمايه المدنيين وخصوصا
الرعايه الاجانب ولكن ايضا البعثات
الدبلوماسيه التي استهدف بعضها اتصلت
كولونيا بشركائنا في الجامعه العربيه
ومنظمه ايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي وستجري
اليوم اتصالات جديده مع هذه الاطراف
الثلاثه ومع الامم المتحده وشركائنا في
مجموعه الدول الخمس الدائمه العضويه في
مجلس
اولويتنا المحافظه على امن رعاينا هناك
والذين نطلب منهم عدم الخروج من منازلهم
لان القتال في الخرطوم يجعل اي جول فيها
امرا خطيرا في هذه المرحله
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم يعني سمعت منذ
قرابه النصف ساعه اشتباكات بمحيط مقر
القياده العامه كيف هو الوضع الان
اما الوضع الان هناك هدوء نسبي او نسميه
هدوء حذر كما تعودنا في الهدمات السابقه
هذا الهدوء كان يعم العديد من المناطق في
ولايه الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث عدا بعض
الاشتباكات في مدينه ام درمان وتحديدا في
منطقه ام بده بقيه المناطق شهدت يعني
اطلاقا للنار ليس ليس كثيف كما كان في
المرات السابقه وبعض اطلاق لمضادات
الطيران كذلك في منطقه بحري ودورمان بقيه
المناطق يهمها هدوء نسبي ربما يكون التزام
جزئي بهذه الهدنه
هل رصدتم سالم اي حركه ليليه وحتى لو كانت
محدوده في اسواق الخرطوم يعني مع دخولنا
بساعات عيد الفطر
نعم هناك اسواق محدوده كذلك تعمل بعض
الاسواق في بعض المناطق في ام درمان مثلا
هناك مناطق فيها جزء من الحيويه والحركه
كذلك لبعض المواطنين لقضاء بعض الاحتياجات
وهناك مناطق ليس فيها اي حركه اسواقها
مغلقه بالكامل مثل مدينه بحريه وكذلك
الخرطوم اما الاسواق في ام درمان الى حد
ما فيها حركه نسبيه اللي بعض المواطنين
وكذلك لبعض الاسواق هنا في بحري وفي
الخرطوم ايضا لا توجد اسواق بل بالعكس
كلها مغلقه بالكامل الحركه فقط في المناطق
التي تشهد توزيعا للمياه لان بحري فيها
ازمه مياه وكذلك الخرطوم وايضا في محطات
الوقود كذلك هناك ازدحام وتقدس بحثا عن
الوقود من المواطنين
سالم بما يخص مبادره القوى الوطنيه من هي
الشخصيات التي تضمها ماذا نعلم عن هذه
المبادره
عن قبول الطرفين لها نتحدث طبعا عن هدنه
لمده ثلاثه ايام ونحن نستمع الى تجدد
الاشتباكات في العاصمه الخرطوم
نعم هذه المبادره
لتقولها مجموعه من القوه الوطنيه ومن
مختلف الاتجاهات الحركه الشعبيه
شمال سالم دعنا نستمع هذه الاصوات
الطبيعيه اصوات الق
[موسيقى]
ذائف اذا تجددت الاشتباكات لليوم السادس
على التوالي بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
تسمع ذوي انفجارات واصفات الاشتباكات
المتقطعه بين الحين والاخر
مع انه مبادره القوى الوطنيه السودانيه
كما ذكرنا منذ قليل
قالت انها تحصلت على موافقه مبدئيه
لوقف اطلاق النار لثلاثه ايام هي ايام عيد
الفطر
سالم اعود اليك
نعم نعم طيب كنا نتحدث عن هذه المبادره
مبادره القوى الوطنيه يعني كيف يمكن تفسير
انه هذه الاطراف طرفين نزاع يبدون موافقه
على يعني هدنه او مبادره ثم تخرق مباشره
يعني هل المشكله بالاراده ام المشكله
بلوجستيا يعني لانه هناك محللين يقولون
انه ربما القائد لا يستطيع ابلاغ كل يعني
المنتمين له او المنضمين تحت لواءه
نعم يمكن ان نقول ان كلا الامرين وارد او
كلاهما صحيح كذلك
لكن الان هناك الجهود الوطنيه وهي التي
يفترض انه هذا هو دور القوى السياسيه
وكذلك القوه المدنيه هذا دور هو ان تقدم
هذه المبادرات وتسعى الى حللت هذه المشكله
لان المشكله السودانيه دائما يفترض ان
تكون حلها سوداني كذلك
عندما يعجز السوناريون بعد ذلك يمكن
الاستعانه بالخليل لكن الان هذه المبادره
مبادره وطنيه هي تسعى لوقف العدائيات
الاغراض الانسانيه الملحه بحسب وصف
المبادره نفسها ومراعاه الظروف التي تمر
بها البلاد من عيد الفطر ايضا مراعاه ظروف
المواطن السوداني في العاصمه وفي الولايات
نعم
هل تسمعني سالم الان يحكوا من الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والاوضاع الامنيه معا وهذا امر
غايه في الخطوره يضاف الى ذلك مساله
الامور الاساسيه في الحياه الان اصبحت
تبدو تذهب الى عدم الرضا من المواطنين
ولان هناك كثير من المشكلات الخدميه فيها
اشكالات كل هذا بسبب تجدد هذا الصراع
واصرار الطرفين على مواصله هذا الصراع لكن
في كل الاحوال هذه المبادره قد يكتب لها
النجاح اذا استطاعت ان تقنع هذه الاطراف
على الاقل بايقاف العمليات في مده ثلاثه
ايام ايام عيد الفطر وتستطيع بعد ذلك في
هذا التحدي في ثلاثه ايام ايصال المساعدات
وكذلك توفير الاحتياجات الضروريه
للمواطنين ثم بعد ذلك تسعى الى حل هذه
الازمه هذا ما تريده المبادره وقد
اكدت هذه المبادره انها تحصلت على
الموافقه المب من اطراف الصراع يوقف
العدائيات خلال ايام عيد الفطر المبارك
وربما هذه البدايه ويبقى على هذه المغادره
ان تكمل بقيه ما يحتاجه المواطن السوداني
سلم الى جانب الاتفاق على وجود هدنه هل
يتم الاتفاق على تامين ممرات انسانيه لعمل
يعني فرق الاسعاف
الجهات العالميه الجهات الانسانيه للعمل
نعم بالنسبه للجهات التي تقدم العمل
الانساني هي تحتاج الى تحديد لمساله
الممرات الانسانيه نفسها فهي تحتاج الى
توضيح هذا المعنى ربما هذا ما يحتاج الى
اجابه من القوات المسلحه السودانيه في هذا
التوقيت بالذات بان ترد عن تفاصيل هذه
الممرات وكيفيه ايصال هذه المساعدات
وكيفيه مرور الامدادات للمواطنين بشكل عام
وكيف تحل القضايا المتعلقه بالمواطن مثل
مشكله المياه والمشاكل الاخرى التي يعاني
منها المواطن من امدادات للوقود
والامدادات الغذائيه كذلك وكذلك
الدعم اللوجستي كذلك للمستشفيات ووصول
الكوادر الطبيه لهذه المستشفيات مباشره
اعمالهم وايضا التعامل مع الجثث الموجوده
ايضا في مناطق متفرقه كل هذه الامور تحتاج
الى رد واضح من القوات المسلحه السودانيه
يعني لا نزال نسمع
اطلاق نار متقطع في محيط مقر القياده
العامه في الخرطوم لم يهدا لم يهدا رغم كل
الهدن التي سبقت هذه الهدى التي قيل ودعا
اليها غوتارش ودعت اليها دول عربيه
وعالميه وايضا مبادره القوى الوطنيه
السودانيه ولكنها كما نستمع تخترق بين
الحين والاخر سالم اذا اردنا الحديث عن
الساكنين في حي المطار يعني ما هي اوضاعهم
الان
يا عم بالنسبه لحي المطار وهذه الاحياء
القريبه جدا من القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني كل هذا المحيط الاحياء الخرطوم
اثنين كذلك والخرطوم ثلاثه وحي المطار
كذلك كل هذه الاحياء يصعب الحركه فيها في
هذا التوقيت فمن الصعب جدا تحديد ما يدور
هناك لانه في هذه المناطق تنتشر بكثافه
هذه القوات من الجانبين القوات الدعم
السريع والجيش السوداني وتحدث اشتباكات
عنيفه احيانا في هذه المناطق المحيطه مما
يجعل مهمه الوصول لتلك المنطقه او الخروج
منها غايه في الصعوبه فهنا يلتزم كل سكان
هنالك بالفلوس في منازلهم واغلاق الابواب
عليهم حتى يستطيعوا ان يصلوا او تصل واحده
من الهدمات التي تعلن الى رؤيه واضحه بان
تكون هناك حقيقيه يستطيعون بعد ذلك الخروج
واجلائهم هناك اطلاق نار كثيف دعنا نستمع
لصوت الطبيعي لو سمحت
نذكر بانه الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو كندا الاطراف السودانيه الى وقف
اطلاق النار ثلاثه ايام على الاقل بمناسبه
عيد الفطر للسماح للمدنيين المحاصرين في
مناطق الصراع بالخروج
اذا العيد هذا العام على السودان ليس سارا
وليس
كسابقه من الاعوام
اجواء صعبه بطبيعه الحال في ظل عدم تيقن
من انه اذا دخلت هذه الهدنه حيض التنفيذ
ام لا ولكن كما نستمع اخترقت
هناك تحذيرات انسانيه من عده جهات ان كانت
من داخل السودان او من خارجه عن سوء الوضع
الانساني ان كان في المستشفيات او حتى
بتامين المواد الغذائيه
للمواطنين السودانيين وخاصه في العاصمه
الخرطوم حيتحذر برنامج الغذاء العالمي من
تاثير استمرار العمليات العسكريه في
السودان ما قد يهدد الملايين من
السودانيين بالجوع البرنامج اشاره الى ان
القتال يعرقل ايصال المساعده الانسانيه
الضروريه بينما يعاني ثلث السكان من صعوبه
الحصول على الغذاء البرنامج اشار ايضا الى
انه تمت سرقه عشره سيارات وسته شاحنات
طعام وتم الاستيلاء على عدد من مكاتب
ومخازن برنامج الغذاء وفقدان 4000 طن من
المواد الغذائيه
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اوضح وزير الصحه
السودانيه هيثم ابراهيم ان هناك حاجه
لتامين مسارات انسانيه لايصال المساعدات
للمحتاجين مؤكدا ان مراكز طبيه تعرضت
للحرق الكامل في السودان
انه يصل لمواقع المستشفيات كذلك محتاجين
لمساله تامين وصول الكوادر الطبيه وايجاد
مسارات لانه برضو هناك عدد من الكوادر
الطبيه تعمل في هذه المستشفيات خمسه او
سته ايام متصله بالليل والنهار
مقدمين العمل الانساني الكبير والجليل
فبالتالي احنا محتاجين لتامين مسارات
الامداد وايصال الوقود للمستشفيات التامه
تحديدا بصوره اساسيه كما نحتاج كذلك
لمساله التامين المستشفيات الصحيه
والامدادات الطبيه
كما افاد وزيره الصحه السوداني بان
مستشفيات العاصمه الخرطوم الاكثر تاثرا
جراء الاشتباكات مشيرا الى ان انظمه
الكهرباء والمياه لحقتها اضرار كبيره
دولات الخرطوم
فيها حوالي
عشرين العام والخاص
تاثرت المستشفيات المركزيه اللي هي فيها
النقاط الاشتباك بصوره كبيره في مركز
الخرطوم المستشفيات التي تعرضت الكيبولات
الكهرباء للقصف والضرب او خزانات المياه
وصارت فيها صعوبه في التشغيل
[موسيقى]
الوضع الصحي في السودان على حافه الهاويه
اغلب المستشفيات خارج الخدمه بلغه الارقام
70% من المرافق الصحيه توقفت عن العمل او
اجبرت على ذلك وفق نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين من اصل 74 مستشفى في العاصمه
هو الولايات القريبه من مناطق الاشتباك 52
منها اصبحت خارج الخدمه تماما تسعه
مستشفيات تعرضت للقصف الشديد ما يعني وجود
اثنين وعشرين مستشفى في المنطقه لكنها
مهدده بالاغلاق في اي لحظه هناك حاليا
يعني حوالي 16 مستشفى في عموم السودان
وبالاخص تسعه في الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب الهجمات العسكريه هناك ما يقارب من
عدد 16 مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن العمل
بسبب الارهاق العاملين السوريين هناك نقص
في توفر الكهرباء والمياه النظيفه
انضم الينا من جديد سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه من الخرطوم سالم يعني برنامج
الغذاء العالمي
ونحن نستمع الى تجدد الاشتباكات مع دخول
يوم العيد عيد الفطر
على العاصمه الخرطوم
سالم اذا كنت اسالك عن برنامج الغذاء
العالمي الذي تحدث عن سرقه مواد غذائيه
وسيارات وشاحنات طعام وايضا كنا سمعنا عن
عمليات نهب تحصل في العاصمه الخرطوم ما
المعلومات المتوفره حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني كذلك وهي شوارع خاليه
اصبحت خاليه من الماره وبسبب الاوضاع
الموجوده الان
فيستغلها المجرمون وحتى الذين يبحثون عن
مثل هذه الامور استغلالا لعدم لغياب
الحكومه وغياب ايضا المواطنين في هذه
الشوارع فيستغلونها بالنهب والسلب كذلك
فربما هنا يغيب دور مهم للشرطه السودانيه
وهي حمايه المدنيين كذلك هذا الامر اوجدته
هذه الظروف من صحه العباره في زاويه وفي
الزاويه الاخرى يحمل المواطنون وكذلك
مختصون كذلك قوات الدعم السريع اما بانها
هي من قامت بالنهر او هي من سمحت به
منذ سته ايام وحتى الساعه سالم هل لمستم
تغيرا بالاسلحه المستخدمه بمحيط القصر
الجمهوري والقياده العامه للجيش
بالنسبه للمحيط القياده العامه والجيش وكل
المناطق هي ذات الاسلحه التي نستمع اليها
دائما لسنا مختصين في الاسلحه ولكن من من
الصوت من الصوت ومن قوه الاصوات ايضا ظروف
الاستماع لهذه يوميا يجعلك تبحث عن هذا
الموضوع كثيرا للاسف ايضا نستمع الى اصوات
مضادات الطائرات نستمع الى صوت الدوشكا
كذلك نستمع الى اصوات المدافع الثقيله
والمدافع الخفيفه المقذوفات باشكالها
نستمع اليها الار بي جي وغيرها كل هذه
يستمع اليها المواطنون
وتحدث ضجيجا في المناطق التي يتم فيها
النزاع كما حدث اليوم في مدينه بحري صباح
اليوم شهدت ضجيجا كثيرا من كل انواع هذه
الاسلحه وكان هناك الطائرات السودانيه
التي تتبع المسلحه السودانيه هجمات على
المواقع التي تتمكن الدعم السريع نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك سالم سنعود اليك طبعا في حال
ورود اي جديد ونحن نستمع الى اصوات
الاشتباكات المتقطعه نستمع
اذا تتواصل
عمليات اطلاق النار والاشتباكات ودويه
الانفجارات
عشيه عيد الفطر في الخرطوم
ذكر مشاهدينا بانه القتال العنيف بين
القوتين العسكريتين الكبيرتين في البلاد
كان انطلق الاسبوع الماضي
بعد ايام من دفع قوات الدعم السريع بنحو
100 اليه نحو قاعده مرويه في الولايه
الشماليه التي تم استعادتها من قبل قوات
الجيش السوداني
اذا ينضم الينا في هذه التغطيه
المباشره لقناه العربيه من الخرطوم مصطفى
ادم احمد مدير منظمه الزرقاء للتنميه
وعضو كونفدريلات المجتمع المدني اهلا بك
سيد مصطفى يعني كيف يعني
تقرا كل ما يحصل على الساحه السودانيه
الان هل هذه
الهدن التي لا تحترم وتجدد الاشتباكات
يمكن ان يبنى سياسيا عليها في الايام
القادمه
طيب في البدله لا بد من التعبير بانه
الحزن العميق لما يدور في السودان بشكل
عام وفي الخرطوم على وجه الخصوص
وطرحهم على شهداء هذا
العمل الانساني ولا
شكل تهديد مباشر لحياه الامنين
نعم
من النور ايضا يامن بحياه يعني علق
الكريمه حتى يعودوا سالمين موطنهم يعني
بالنسبه لسؤالك حقيقه
الان في الخرطوم حرب عباسيه يعني
روعت الامنين يعني حرب داخل مدينه كبيره
جدا يطردون مدينه كبيره جدا تضم اكثر من
12 الى 13 مليون
عدد كبير يعني من المواطنين
وهم الان بيعيشوا كل اللحظات السته ايام
الماضيه تحت وابي من الرصاص ومن
كبير جدا من الدبابات من الغازات من كل
انواع الاسلحه ممكن تكون الخطيره
يعني ما ما تعدوا لها ولا حايشين حياه
مدنيه حياه مستغربه
الهدن والاعلانات حقيقه ما شايف انه ممكن
تقيم لانه هو معجز نظامي بحالك ماليزيا
يعني ما شايف انه يعني بالامكان يعني
نعم التحكم والسيطره يعني بعد ذلك
المناخذه يعني شنو الجمعيه الجهات اللي
بتحدد
المراقبه للموضوع بتاع
الوقفه
الاقتتال او حتى المسارات الممكن يعني من
عبرها
اذا اردنا الحديث عن الناحيه الانسانيه
هناك تحذيرات عالميه من كارثه واصلا
السودان كان يعاني من ازمه اقتصاديه
انسانيه خانقه الان المؤسسات الانسانيه
الدوليه او يعني اللي هي داخليه كيف تعمل
هي الان يعني الجميع يجمع بانه لا مسارات
امنه ما الصعوبات الاخرى التي تواجهها
الصعوبات الاكبر واجهت يعني
وكالات الامم المتحده هي كان ممكن تكون
بدور كبير جدا في مثل هذه الازمات
ومنظمات الدوليه هي اول من استهدفت تم
استهداف كبير جدا للمنظمات
الدوليه على خصوص
وسياراتهم وقلت حتى يعني الموظفين
وحتى المنظمات الوطنيه المنظمات الوطنيه
لم يعني
مثل هذه الاحداث يعني اكثر من المنظمه
يعني منظمه الناس تناس في دارفور ومنظمه
بالمنظمات غيرها تعرضت للنهب
وللسلباء منظمات ايام نفسها الان اصبحت هي
هدف مباشر جدا للسلب وبالتالي يصلح الامر
في تحديد تحديد كبير جدا العمل الانساني
في كيفيه اداره العمل الانساني ظروف
المروعه والخطيره جدا والمهدده المهدده
الموظفين المهدد الحركه
المنظمات محدده للنشاطه وبالتالي بيكون
يعني بشكل خطوره كبيره جدا
الا الا في الفتره العصيبه اللي ممكن تقوم
بها المنظمات ممكن تقوم بعمل كبير جدا بان
هي يعني
بتاعه العلاج في اطار العمل العلاجي مصطفى
بانه تقول انه المنظمات الانسانيه كان
العالميه او او حتى الوطنيه استهدفت بشكل
مباشر وتنهب
كيف يمكن
للمواطن السوداني خاصه بالعاصمه الخرطوم
تدبر امره ان كان من ناحيه الوصول الى
مستشفى ان كان من ناحيه التزود بالطعام
والشراب ونعرف بان هناك ازمه مياه
بالخرطوم
لان البدايه حقيقه كان التفكير لفم كيفيه
يعني التعامل مع مثل هذا الظروف
الصعبه حقيقه ظهرت عدد من المبادلات وعدد
من العمل التنسيقي ما بيننا كمنظمات ما
بين عدد كبير جدا من الناس الناشطين في
العمل
واتعملت يعني جروبات يعني مثلا على مستوى
الخرطوم في عدد من الجروبات هي بتجمع كل
الملايين اي يعني مدينه تكون مفصوله
كيفيه التعامل معها هي سواء كان في
الادويه سواء كان في الموضوع تاع المياه
في موضوع الغاز في هذه التحرك لسؤال
الامنه وهكذا
ايضا في موضوع المياه موضوع موضوع اللي
كان حقيقه كبيره جدا نتحركت
حركه الدفاع المدني
بادوار جيده جدا على المستشفيات ايضا يعني
تم يعني بعض المنظمات والعمل الناشطين من
الشباب والشابات لانه بالنسبه للاطفال هم
اطفال سنه في منطقه السجانه ودي منطقه
المجموعه دي تعرضت ايضا يعني لانه ما فيش
ما فيش عايزين خدمات يوميه من الناحيه
بتاعه الغذاء الالبان موضوع البامبرز
موضوع الحاجات اللي هم الاطفال يعني
تقديم خدمات ودي كانت من المسائل اللي
ممكن تكوني يعني ممكن تكون يعني شكلت يعني
تهديد مباشر
لكن نجحتاج العمل ده بيتين في الظرف صعب
جدا لانه في ضمانات ما في ضمانات التحرك
ما في شيء يعني يعني
امنه ما في شيء اشارات الملحه الان
الحاجات المديحه الان هي موضوع الدوام
مسبب المستشفيات بالتاكيد
وقطاع صحي يعني
كبيره جدا قبل هذه الازمه
بهذه الازمه واصبحت هي المستشفى يعني
اهداف عسكريه
المشاكل كبيره جدا واوقف يعني عدد من
المستشفيات تقريبا
اصبحت مشكله
ويتعدل اعدام الادويه لانه في اطفال كثير
جدا من الاطفال السرطان هؤلاء تظهرون
الناس
كذا لا ينتظرون
وحاجات دوريه تنتظر هذه الاشياء بالتاكيد
لحياه كثير جدا من المواطنين وحيات كثيره
جدا من الاطفال بالنسبه للاطفال السرطان
وغير من اطفال
المساله
الصحيه هي الاولويه القصوى هي الاولي الان
بالنسبه لهذا الظرف الانساني المعقد وده
بالتالي يتطلب يعني
مباشره بالمساله بتاعه
ايقاف الحوت من خلالها ممكن يتم يعني
المسائل سريعه جدا ممكن يكون يعني عمل
الازعاج سريع مثلا حتى اخلاء سريعنا بعض
المرضى لمناطق ممكن تقول اكثر امانا او
للمستشفيات فيها حركه وفيها نشاط ايضا
بيتطلب عن التامين الكباري لان العاصمه
المثلثه ايضا مربوطه بالكبائر والحركه
فيها بتكون في عدم المستشفيات ممكن تكون
في بعض المدن تعمل في المرضى يكون في
مدينه لا تعمل فيها مستشفيات ويكون هي
معطله مثلا من خلال الحركه بالنسبه يعني
وهذه الكباريه ايضا امنه ومهمنه وما في اي
نوع من الاعتراضات وفي نوع من الاشكالات
بحيث انه يضمن هذا المريض انه يوصل
للمستشفى بتاعه ويتناول او يتلقى
التعامل نعم نعم من الخرطوم مصطفى ادم
احمد مدير منظمه الزرقاء للتنميه
القتال لا يتوقف في السودان لكن خدمه
المياه والكهرباء توقفت ازمه انسانيه
خانقه تلوح في سماء البلاد اجزاء واسعه
بالاحياء السكنيه في العاصمه تعاني شحا
شديدا في مياه الشرب بعد نقص الامداد
المائي من المحطات المزوده محطات المياه
الرئيسيه بالعاصمه تعرضت لاضرار بالغه جر
الاشتباكات الازمه تفاقمت اكثر مع ارتفاع
درجات الحراره وزياده استهلاك المياه في
شهر رمضان اما انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
فبات عاديا وحكايه مالوفه
وان عاد برزت مشكله توقف شراء الخدمه من
التطبيقات البنكيه
دعونا اذا نذكر باخر المستجدات في السودان
حيث قالت القوى الوطنيه السودانيه انها
تحصلت على موافقه مبدئيه من طرفي الصراع
على مبادره لوقف الاشتباكات خلال ايام
العيد واكدت القوى انها ستقدم مبادره
شامله لوقف النار والحوار لحل الخلافات
واشارت الى ان نتيجه المساعي لمبادرتها
ستكون خلال الساعات القادمه
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم رئيس لجنه
السياسات في حزب الامه القوميه امام الحلو
اهلا بك سيد امام يعني
الجامعه العربيه الان تقول بانها سترسل
وفدا الى السودان
لمحاوله تهدئه
الامور
والمطالبه بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
فعليا سيد امام كيف لمبادره تتحدث عنها
القوى الوطنيه السودانيه
ان تنجح وتقول بانها تحصلت على موافقه
مبدئيه بالوقت اللي لازلنا نستمع الى
الاشتباكات الليليه بمحيط القصر
الجمهوري وايضا القياده العامه يعني على
ماذا تبنى هذه المبادرات
اهلا مرحبا استاذ راضيه ومرحب بقناه
العربيه
واسمحي لي ان اهني الامه الاسلاميه بعيد
الفطر المبارك كل عام وانت بخير الشعب
السوداني
بمناسبه عيد الفطر المبارك
واتمنى انه يعود العيد
والشعب السوداني في وضع افضل
من هذا
الايام الصعيبه
والموسيكل
الشعب السوداني فذلك لا ترحم على شهدائنا
يعني فقط ارواحهم في الايام القليله السته
ايام الماضيه للجراء الاشتباكات بين ابناء
السودان
وكذلك الجرحى
الاف الموتى والاف الجرحى من هذا الوضع
الصعب
نحن يعني في القوى السياسيه
تزعم بكل الاتجاهات
لوقف الاشتباك والقتال الان
وفي هذا الاطار اي مبادره سودانيه مرحب
بها واي محاوله لوقف الاقتتال عمل مطلوب
من القوه المدنيه والسياسيه والمجتمعيه
الحزنه المبادره المعلنه القوى الوطنيه هي
لم تعلن عن الاتفاق ولذلك ما زالت في طور
المفاوضات مع الطرفين
وحسب الاعلان الصدر انه وجدت قبول مبدئي
لكن هذا لا يعني توقف القتال ونامل انه
ينجحوا خلال كما او ردوا خلال الساعات
القادمه انه يتوصل الى اتفاق
ما العثرات حتى تحصلتم فقط على موافقه
مبدئيه
لم اعتقد انه في بعض التفاصيل الفنيه فيما
يتعلق
الهدنه وده متعلق ببعض الفنيات فيما تتعلق
بتحرك القوات وتعرف بالنسبه
الجسور واغلاقه في بعض التفاصيل
اللي هم شغالين عليها الان
يعني عندي تفصيل عنها كثيرا ولكن هناك بعض
الفنيات ولكن اذا تم الاتفاق على وقف
الاقتتال
الان وده المطلوب فورا وقف الاشتباكات باي
شكل من الاشكال وانا اعتقد انه هذه لا
تحتاج الى تفاصيل فنيه على امه وقفوا
اطلاق النار هو كله طرف فيه مكانه الان
الى ان الناس ينتقلوا الى مرحله متطوره
فيما يتعلق به الهدنه
المرحله اللي تليها فيما يتعلق بالجلوس
والتفاوض حول
وجود علاج
للاختلافات الموجوده اما بالنسبه الى
حديثك عن الجامعه العربيه
يعني
مطلوب يعني الدعم الدولي في مسانده
المبادرات السودانيه
وانا اعتقد انه مهم جدا انه نحسب
المبادرات في الاطار الوطني حتى لا تتشعب
المحاولات وتضيع
الوطني ولكن هل للداخل دور الان يعني ليس
دور او صوت مسموع اصلا لانه كل ما نسمعه
من الخرطوم الان هو اصوات الاشتباكات لا
مبادرات سيد امام حقيقيه بمعنى توقف ما
يحصل
نعم صحيح الان صوت
صوت الرصاص والقنابل هو الصوت العالي ولكن
المبادرات الوطنيه
مختلف
خلفياته ومنطلقاته هي الاساس في
الوصول الى علاج لانه نحن في المجتمع
السوداني اكثر درايه
بالمشاكل اللي الان تدور والادت الى هذا
الصراع العسكري
وانا اعتقد انه
التدخلات
الدوليه والاجنبيه
اذا
لم تتوحد نفسها ودعمت المجهود الداخلي
الوطني
ستسبب في كثير من تعقيد الازمات وفي تجارب
معروفه في المنطقه عندنا ولذلك نحن نعمل
انه خاصه المنظمات والمؤسسات الدوليه
انها توحد موقفه في دعم المجهود الداخلي
والتاثير بتاع المجتمع الدولي معروف
قدراته يعني بما انه مبادراتكم هي بنيه
صادقه وايقاف ما يحصل على الارض لماذا لا
تتجهون الى يعني القيام بخطوات اكبر
مثل الصيام مدني مثل
النزول الى الشارع انه هذه القوه يجب ان
تتوقف الان يجب ان توقف هذه الاشتباكات
لانه يعني الضحيه هو الشعب والمدنيين
السودانيين يعني
نعم صحيح كحديث ومعقول نحن اولا
مهم جدا لانه نحن نحدد انه ما يحدث الان
من صراع محتدم في داخل المدن هو
انعكاس مباشر لفشل النخبه العسكريه في
اداره شؤون البلاد
ولا فشل وانا اعتقد انه دي نهايه
يعني تسلط النخبه العسكريه على مقاليد
البلاد
وان احنا على عقود طويله جدا كنا تحت
اداره
النخبه العسكريه
الان لا بد من تحول تام الى مدنيه
الحكم وده يحتاج الى ترتيب
المقاومه الانظمه العسكريه ضمن طبيعه
الشعب السوداني
بتحتاج الى
اليات المقاومه ولكن نحن الان الان بنواجه
كشعب اعزل واصلا نحن حراكنا حراك سلمي
الان بنواجه الموقف لا نملك فيه ادوات
القتال العنيف نحن نتحامل بالتنميه وهذه
تحتاج ولكن الشعب السوداني الان وصل الى
قناعتها هامه انه النخبه العسكريه لن
تستمر في حكم السودان مره اخرى هذه
السياسيه وهذه القناعه التي تقول بانها
اصبحت لدى
السودانيين هل يمكن او هل سيسمح
هذان الجنرلين بان يخرجا من الصوره
السياسيه للسودان بعد كل هذه الاشتباكات
وكل هذا النزاع المسلح المحتدم منذ سته
ايام
نعم حتما سيخرج لانه هم اصلا الطرفين
موقعين على الاتفاق الايطالي في 5 ديسمبر
بالخروج من السياسه وبالخروج من السلطه
ومن باب اولى انه هم الاثنين الان يعلنون
انه
بعد انتهاء هذه المعارك سيواصل في العمليه
السياسيه اللي هي بتنتهي بخروج العسكر من
السكر
يحدث الان هو لكي يبقوا بالسلطه
طبعا هو صراع على السلطه الان والان
الصراع سياسي نحن نعلم ذلك ولكن
الشعب عنده الكلمه النهائيه يعني هذا
الصراع الان على السلطه
لن يدوم كثيرا
وفي النهايه تستفيد منه قوه
تجعى الى اجهاض ثوره ديسمبر وتستفيد منه
قوه باستعاده نظام الانقاذ ولذلك نحن
نخاطب الفصيلين الان
القياده القوات المسلحه وقياده الدعم
السريع في انه تتوقف هذه المعرفه العبثيه
للسفريه ووقف الاقتتال والجلوس مع القوه
المدنيه متى سيعمل الثوره السياسي متى
سيجلس البرهان وحماتي على طاوله واحده وما
الرساله التي توجهها للرجلين
اوجه للرساله انه اول حاجه السلاح اللي
الان هم يعني
يتقاتل به وهذا السلاح الشعب السوداني
وسلاح الشعب السوداني ينبغي ان لا يوجه
الى صدور ابناء الشعب
السودانية تحمله هم الاثنين مباشره ولذلك
ابو الشعب السوداني موجود
ومستمر والامه السودانيه مستمره
المواقع السياسيه والعسكريه متقلبه سياتي
يوم
للتحقيق في ماذا حدث
ادى الى هذا الوضع المدمر وداء سيتحمل هم
مسؤوليته مباشره المجله الثانيه عليهم
فعلا انه يتحلوا بالشجاعه في انه يوقف هذا
الدمار
لطال الان كل السودان وهذا الدمار هم
مسؤولين منه مباشره
لا نحفي احد من البدله الثالثه انه الشعب
السوداني الان يراقب ويتابع وهو في وضع
مؤلم وحزين ولكن هذه المساله القرار للشعب
السوداني وينبغي انه الاحتكام الى الشعب
السوداني بشكل من الاشكال اللي تسرع في
الانتقال هم الان يتحدثوا عن الدعمهم
للانتقال الديمقراطي وينبغي ان يكون
الكلام بيان بالعمل وليس تصريحات اعلاميه
لمكتسبات هذه المعركه الشعب السوداني الان
كل يتابع
العالم
المجتمع الاسره الدوليه تدعم مواقف الشعب
السوداني في التحول المدني ولذلك انا
اعتقد انه مهما طال امت هذا الصدام سينتهي
حتما بانتصار الشعب
السودانية اذا استمر امد هذا الصراع لا لن
تحدث حرب اهليه لانه العناصر للحرب
الاهليه في المجتمع السوداني غير متوفره
نحن الشعب عندنا تنوع كبير ولكن نزعه الى
الوحده وما حدث في الماضيه الدرس اللي انا
كبير جدا في انه لن نسمح بتكون في حرب
اهليه شعب السوداني عنده وعي سياسي كبير
الشعب السوداني تواف الى الحريه
والديمقراطيه
والحكم المدني ولذلك الصراع الان انا
اعتقد انه الصراع الان ونهايه هيمنه
النخبه العسكريه على مقاليد
الامور في السودان وحتما حننتقل الى الى
الى
وضع افضل بحكم مدني حكم قائم على الحكم
الراشد وقائم على مبادئ حقوق الانسان
المعروفه دوليا بالمبادئ الحننتقل بها
قريبا ان شاء الله الى اداره شؤون بلادنا
وانا متفائل جدا انه في
يعني في في
المننن في طي المحن والمزايا في طي
البلايا يعني نحن ننظر دائما الى الفرص
نعم يمكن في داخل هذه الكوارث انه كيف
نوظيفه لمصلحه السودان بلدنا
نحن نقدم هذه القضيه شكرا جزيلا لك رئيس
لجنه السياسات في حزب الامه القومي امام
الحلو شكرا
على طاوله العشاء اجتمع ليلا وفي ساحه
القتال توجه صباحا هذه تفاصيل الساعه
الاخيره قبل انزلاق السودان الى الصراع
بين البرهان وحميتي وفق صحيفه نيويورك
ضجيج اليات العسكر لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنارين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق رصاصه الاولى
طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات تنازلات
بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل التنافس بينهما
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وفيما كانت
الالات العسكريه المتنافسه تستعد للقتال
تدفقت القوات بهدوء على معسكرات الجيش
المتنافسه في جميع انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم
بدايه الخلاف وبحسب الصحيفه خرجت من قلق
حمد المتمتل باختراق الجيش من قبل موالينا
للنظام السابق فيما بدات المخابرات
العسكريه بقياده البرهان في اخبار
المسؤولين الاجانب بان حمد حاول سرا
استيراد طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من
تركيا لتعزيز قوته فالخلافات لوحدت حتى
بين افراد الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاملوا كقوتين متنافستان وليس كلمتين ضمن
نفس الدوله لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم الخلاف
اكثر محاوله الاتفاق على دمج القوتين في
جيش واحد خصوصا ان هذه العمليه ستخرج
حمدتي الخاسر الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوث الامريكي حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي
الباشا محمد تطبيق اهلا بك سيد
طبيق يعني هل من امل باستجابه الطرفين
لهدنه العيد التي دعت اليها اطراف دوليه
وحتى وطنيه سودانيه
مرحب
وكل عام وانتم بخير
ان يحسن دماء السودانيين في هذه الايام
يعني المباركه باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى
الهدنه في ايام العيد يعني مطلب لكل الشعب
السوداني ومطلب لكل يعني
الوسطاء للالتزام بهدنه في يعني ايام
العيد الثلاث وهذا يعني انا افتكر انه حقل
الشعب السوداني وحقن
للمواطن العالقه الان ويعيش ظروف قاسيه
جدا حتى يستطيع ان يشعر بعيد الفطر يعني
المبارك وحتى يستطيع ان تكون هنالك مساحه
لمد المستشفيات بالادويه
ومد المحلات التجاريه بالبضايا حتى يعني
يستطيع المواطن السوداني من شراء دوائي
ومن شراء
يعني
المستلزمات
الاسريه فلا بد من يعني من استجابه يعني
من الطلبيه
يجب ان تاتي ان كان من مبادره خارجيه او
داخليه وطنيه واخر المبادرات الوطنيه او
ابرزها فعليا لانه هي الاولى مبادره القوى
الوطنيه السودانيه ما فرص نجاحها
فرص النجاح الان يعني
ممكن تتاكد من التزام الطرفين واستجابتهم
الى هذه النداءات الانسانيه العاجله يعني
الى هذه يعني الهدنه فاذا استجاب الطرفين
انا اعتقد ان تكون هنالك يعني
واتمنى ان ان تستمر هذه الهدنه الى وقف
شامل لاطلاق النار والرجوع الى تحكيم صوت
العقلي والتفاوض من اجل يعني
من المعرقل السيد
الباشا الان لهذه المبادرات
والله انا اعتقد يعني هنالك
الطرف الذي
يعني يرى في في استمرار الاستمرار القتال
والاشتباكات الذي اعتقد انه سوف يحسم
المعركه
يعني البندقيه وهو الذي يعتقد
يعني عرقل هذه هذه يعني هذه
الهدنه الطرف الذي يعني يرى انه هو لابد
من حسم الامر عسكريا
يعني يراهنان على الحسم العسكري بين
التصريحات الطرفين منذ بدايه الاشتباك
وحتى اليوم هذا ما يبدو يعني من خلال
التصريحات وهو مؤشر بطبيعه الحال خطير
يعني ينظر بطول امد هذه الازمه
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من الخرطوم المحلل
السياسي الباشا محمد طبيق
والان الى موجز لاهم الانباء حول العالم
تلقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان اتصالا هاتفيا من نظيره
الايرانيه حسين امير عبداللهيان تتقال
رقابه لعده موضوعات بين البلدين وناقشا ما
تم الاتفاق عليه اخيرا بين البلدين في
الصين وناقش ايضا الخطوات المقبله لتعزيز
العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران
اكد المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض جون كاربي
ان الولايات المتحده لم تتخذ اي قرار بعد
بشان تصنيف مجموعه فاجنر التي تحاول
السيطره على مدينه باخموت في شرق اوكرانيا
كمنظمه ارهابيه اجنبيه وقال كاربي في
افاده صحفيه انه لم يتوصل بعد لمثل هذا
القرار وليس لديه ما يقدمه بهذا الشان
نقلت صحيفه تايمز عن وزير الدفاع يوفالنت
قوله ان اسرائيل قد تواجه حربا متعدده
الجبهات في المستقبل القريب وقال جالنت
وفقا للصحيفه انه انتهى عصر الصراعات
المحدوده وان البلاد بصدد حقبه امنيه
جديده قد تشهد تهديدا حقيقيا على جبع او
عده جبهات في وقت واحد
دعت منظمه العفو الدوليه جماعه الحوثي
اليمنيه اليوم الى اجراء تحقيق سريع وشفاف
في حادث تدافع في صنعاء والذي اسفر عن
مقتل ما لا يقل عن 85 شخصا واصابه اكثر من
300 وقالت نائبه مديره المكتب الاقليمي
للشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا بالمنظمه انه
يجب تقديم المشتبه في وقوفهم وراء الحادث
للعداله داعيه الحوثيين الى الاحجام عن اي
تدخل في توصيل المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المدنيين
نعود لتطورات الاشتباكات في السودان
وتتابع معكم هذه التغطيه الزميله ميسون
الواي هيد كل عام وانت بخير ميسون ولكل
المشاهدين ومع التمنيات طبعا للسودان
بالامان والسلام شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات